what is up home fries and hashbrowns
it's a sunday afternoon my name is jerry
and i'm here to give you a little
another first impressions video it's
been a busy weekend at the cinema uh
just making up for some lost time or
something like that so here we go uh me
and ryan last night checked out the new
Expendables film yes the expendables 3
the third in a line of nostalgia action
motion pictures spearheaded by none
other than Sylvester Stallone Sly
Stallone for those of you know him this
is the third film the expendables
franchise and I'm going to cuff I feel
like every time I do one of these
reviews I'm like I have to level with
you guys about something and today that
thing is that I have not seen the first
film I have not I wasn't really
interested in it and I didn't get around
to seeing it there was something else
that came out or whatever I can't
remember how long it goes was um so I
haven't seen the first film but I have
seen the second film and from what I've
heard the second film improves on the
first if for no other reason that it's
just more fun a little less overly
serious and I get the sense that that's
what these Expendables movies have sort
of started to do is like each time we do
this it gets a little less
self-important and a little more
humorous a little more fun you know
still gritty when they need to be but
you know fun so um I wasn't champing at
the bit to see this but I had a good
time with the second movie I saw it with
some friends we had a few drinks these
were guys who are really into van Dam
and and you know all these guys old
movies so that's the kind of audience
you really want to see this with it's
just people who have the nostalgia um so
the expendables 3 it's roughly the same
formula we're gonna get a bunch of old
action stars together and we're gonna
you know have them go out on this gritty
violent you know mission you know this
impossible mission that they're going to
have to sort of work together and pull
through and along the way a bunch of
people are going to stop by who you
remember in
and you know for the most part of the
expendables 3 does keep this formula
alive but they do take some efforts to
kind of bridge the gap there's a lot of
ideas in this film or at least you know
themes touched upon with regard to
getting old you know being passed your
time and past your prime and you know
you know young man's game and all that
stuff newfangled technology versus you
know old-fashioned fighting skills and
guns and knives and whatnot and that's
it's actually kind of interesting with
this movie and in a sense i mean this
movie i feel like you kind of gotta take
on on two separate levels because as I'm
moving you know if you're if you're
thinking critically it's kind of a holy
mess it jumps back and forth between
this this gritty violence and then you
know these have pretty wacky scenes and
then sometimes it's funny because it is
attending to be and then sometimes it's
funny just because it's kind of bad so
it's it's a very mixed experience it in
terms of at least cinematic quality I
don't know what it is about these movies
because I notices it with the second one
and I heard it about the first one it's
even if you have a low budget which I
get the sense this might have um it's
not that hard to get a hold of a read
nowadays like independent films films
with no money can get a read or an Alexa
or at least a pretty good camera and
these films has such inconsistent
cinematography which just seems strange
to me there are a lot of like
establishing shots and stuff that looked
like they were shot on you know prosumer
grain DSLRs and stuff so that's sort of
a problem that carries over I feel from
the second movie I'm also surprised
because you know i mean the action is a
good deal of the point of this movie the
action and these sort of older action
movie archetypes are the point of this
movie are what this movie's meat
potatoes are what it's nostalgia is
for and I had to wonder if our way
through like what happened to their
budget was the second one just not that
successful do they have a smaller budget
here because there is a lot of CG that's
really apparent you know there's CG
helicopters a lot of CG explosions
there's even CG water in a pond seen you
know there's a lot of CG all over this
movie that's not all that good cg that's
pretty apparent and you'd think that for
a big franchise action movie aah
sunlight for as much money as you think
stallone could get they might be able to
afford some better effects or or some
practical effects because I mean these
movies are harkening back to a time
where practical effects were much more
widely used so that was a little strange
to me you know this film is sort of all
over the place you know it's like you
have this dialogue where some of it is
you know intentionally cheesy you know
the sort of one-liners you would get in
the kind of movies that this harkens
back to but some of the dialogue is also
just kind of flat just because it's
plaid and you can always sort of tell
the difference and what's interesting we
have others movie too is that you have
so many different people in it who's
acting capability and whose approach to
their characters is so wildly different
on the one hand you've got like Mel
Gibson who's giving like a legitimately
powerful
moments at least for this kind of thing
and then you've got you know I Antonio
Banderas who's a really over-the-top
character brings a lot of humor into
things and you have you know Stallone
it's really serious it does a pretty
good job you know you've got Kelsey
Grammer in there who brings a certain
level of style to his performance then
you've got Jason Statham Houston's
pretty believable and then you've got
these other guys who are sort of a range
from stiff to you know over the top to
all kinds of things and somehow this all
feels like they're in the same movie
even though they're not all acting like
they're in the same movie so that's
strange but a neat I guess the editing
is kind of all over the place the pace
is a little all over the place and in
terms of the action the action itself is
cool a lot of the time it's just the way
they capture it it's just sort of
workmen like it's not really shot all
that remarkably like there were cool set
pieces and the stuff that they're doing
is cool but the action itself isn't
particularly flashy are particularly
nicely captured which worries me a
little bit for the remake of the rape
because I guess Patrick Hughes who
directed this is going to direct that
and also you know you just have this
movie that has a bunch of different
kinds of scenes so sometimes it's being
a fun action flick and sometimes really
serious and then sometimes it's over the
top with this sort of wacky humor um and
for some reason
I guess it here's the thing as a film
the expendables 3 is not very good it's
not a very good film you know if you
want to be critical about it it's not a
very good film there's a lot of
technical and consistency there's a lot
of performance and consistency the
script certainly leaves a lot to be
desired however I don't get the sense
that this movie necessarily minds Elvis
thing because this movie is an homage to
slash and attempt to keep alive you know
the gritty action movies and the heroes
who brought those things to life those
movies were all cheesy into an extent so
is this so just as a film experience as
inconsistent as it is as it can be by
the time it was all said and done as a
complete halt I did have a good time the
times you're supposed to feel first
alone is this lone wolf and stuff like
that they're affected enough the action
is cool enough there's a lot of humor
and I guess the humerus is sort of the
best asset this movie has in addition to
a couple of the performances one of
which is Antonio Banderas who is a lot
of fun to watch he is he is clearly
having a blast they kind of let him off
the leash to be this really gung-ho
excited eccentric guy and I know some
people find him annoying I can totally
see why but I was all giggles whenever
he was on Scooby I loved him in this
movie and the other person is Mel Gibson
mel gibson is the villain in this and
he's fantastic i mean every time he's on
screen he elevates the movie say what
you will about the man as a person he's
a damn fine actor and i was thinking the
first time they really get a scene with
him and he gets to have you know a
monologue that seen that little
interrogation bit is better than the
entirety of the movie that came before
it not to say that the movie
before that you know his scenes wasn't
fun but his scenes he is legitimately
good in this movie and he brings a
certain way to his performance he's
still a fat guy but you understand so
Mel Gibson is definitely stand out in
this movie and you know I always liked
Dolph Lundgren in these I think he's
pretty fun the way he plays his
character kelsey Grammer's really good
at Harrison Ford is also in this and at
first when he came on screen I was like
ah here we go you know here's he reminds
me of a grumpy bowl of oatmeal nowadays
but uh but he's even fun in this and
he's you know you know he's having a
good time with it that's nice to see I
was bummed personally the Terry Crews
isn't in this movie a whole lot because
he was one of my very favorite things
about Expendables 2 but Jason Statham's
good and and they bring in wesley snipes
which is a little awkward just because
like the second they bring him in Terry
Crews leaves and it's like why can't we
have more than one black action hero but
Wesley Snipes is a lot of fun to watch
too he kind of feels like he's acting in
some kind of 70s blaxploitation movie
because he's a bit over the top and you
know he's got a really eccentric lingo
some of the time and they really play up
his you know but she's blowing badassery
especially when he's in the when we
first see him on screen so this movie
does sort of flirt with the line between
like heightened action and realistic
action and the new guys the young people
that this movie brings in are actually
pretty good you sort of start out being
like why are you watching these people
when who is supposed to be about you
know these older action heroes but when
you get to know they're on the level
with the movie and they're fun to watch
then when they're all working together
you know it's right it's very enjoyable
so you know technically speaking as a
daisy film yeah this is not all
it's maybe not worth top dollar at the
theater but if this is your jam if you
can get down with you know nostalgia and
you know action heroes and stuff like
that and you know beefy action scenes in
this movie is probably for you you know
it's not great but you'll probably have
a good time and that's I get this if
that's what these movies are most
concerned about it for that they are
successful at least for me the last
thing I'll say is a lot of people are
freaking out about this being pg-13 they
want to I guess bring in the younger
crowds stuff like that there's you know
it's the movies seems to wear that if
not on its sleeve at least somewhere on
its jacket and the bee gees our team
doesn't really hurt in fact i found a
pg-13 rating kind of disturbing for this
because even though there's no blood i'm
sure that's how they got away with it he
actually is still really gritty and
still very violent and still shot in
such a way that it feels violent so i
feel like this could have been an
r-rated movie it's just the absolute
blood makes it not so and that freaked
me out a little bit just because you
know if we're gonna have a rating system
I couldn't help but wonder part way
through this movie like okay who paid
for this movie to be pg-13 because it's
clearly more violent than most pg-13
movies on to me but anyhow I digress so
that's it for now I gotta imagine
they're gonna do another one of these
unless they they don't make a lot of
money so who would you like to see you
want them to add more young people to
this and sort of bridge that gap are
their heroes you'd like to see more or
is there something you know sort of
different or more eccentric you'd like
to see them do with the plot because
it's another thing I sort of thought it
was like if they could really commit to
just really having fun with these they
could do a lot of wacky [ __ ] I don't
know if they would be into that
yeah they could bend these in certain
you know science fictiony ways um but
yes that's it for now expendables 3 is
the film I am Jerry shears